this is a production of Cornell
University
so today I'd like to talk to gourmet
mushrooms in the context of the AG
report new system called forest market
for smart man anticipating our AG report
be has to do with cultivating trees and
crops together for social environmental
and economic reasons forest farm is just
one particular practice on a total of
five tech report progress today include
alley cropping riparian buffers so sold
faster and with them and of course for a
smart time well it's quite appropriate
for the other state over sixty five
percent of the land area of the Earth's
data sources and about eighty percent of
that is privately owned force there's a
lot of interesting wood lot of forest
owners
have a girl at our safe non-tariff
forest products they're quite diverse
these are just some examples of the
non-intercourse practices we grow here
began the creation cycle we wrote
additionals like American ginseng
goldenseal mushrooms of course a couple
of different times not broken tables
different places to grow walnuts and
hickory nuts various food crops
apocalypse which are desperate this year
hundreds of crops
ferry crosses open another one inside
we take manager before shade and
they're talking about each of these
aspects of our partner program research
we conduct primarily in Iran for
teaching as I mentioned we have a course
called practicum in forest farming here
at the mechanics which is on the south
edge of campus just be long Jordan and
outreach extension require with a number
of different extension educators a
couple of different companies and we
have a three-year sentiment right now by
Commission there so you might ask the
question why Roma especially when you
look at the price tag on this American
ginseng two to three hundred dollars a
pound
Broadway you've cultivated before speed
enforcement collected quietly so when
you just look at the dollar figures the
value of the problem why would we ever
bother grow mushrooms at twelve to
sixteen dollars
there's some good reasons actually it
takes the case of ginseng it's eight or
more years before mature sides ready to
harvest educational fun in case of
shiitake mushrooms once you inoculate a
lot of the trade recruits mushrooms
about one here and it's going to
continue producing for three forty five
years at one to two pounds of here times
five years at $16 that's a fair amount
of money for that bar when you grow its
thing it takes seven years munching
harvested there's nothing left so you
don't get multiple years ago and
so you've seen that there's certain
amount keeping are advantages to growing
mushrooms in horse when I want someone
asks me what should I grow drop 30-pin
ginseng and I try to tell them if you're
gonna run ginseng that's fine they maybe
start out with shiitake mushrooms at the
same time so you don't have to wait
eight years of discovery so let's talk
more about is the genus continue up and
ratings it's native to China Korea and
Japan the XI in shiitake refers to the
she tree which is guess any houses
custer data
it's a navigation family so it's close
relative of our oaks beach and we'll
talk about using those equations or
substrate
it's a besito messy fungus and it's a
separate feeds on earth uh just dead
organic matter that is to say there's
not a piper rising fungus and it is not
a parasite of
for the production cycle for this fungus
hey as I do
gasps Brian to bring that log back Brian
so close my graduation
so the process starts with usually in
the springtime cutting down the live
tree you can't be a tree hugger
you have to be ready to cut down live
freeze and you cut those trees into
three foot lengths call these bolts take
those bolts if you drill holes using
high speed these are students in my
class was Paul drilling holes in
Australia logs once you drilled a hole
of us seven sixteenths of diameter as
your turkey you take spawn which is you
think this plastic bag here filled with
sawdust a substrate and mycelium of the
fungus has been allowed to grow and
colonize that sawdust substrate and this
pool right here okay this guy's holding
in the population you pick up some spawn
there and sawdust and put it there
pushing into the pulse and you grill
about 30 holes got 30 slugs of an
optimum next step is to paint them off
with a molten wax cheese wax and then
you're ready to take them to the lake
out of here how late are is lay down box
but it's a little more than that to a
good Lane you are have some
characteristics of a very dense canopy
for shade it's best if you have a proper
canopy
deciduous canopies in the where time
that leaves fall off and light come
through there can't be one temperatures
involved right now the log can dry out
their level surfaces both people try
easel dental service and then there are
several different stacking systems this
is a low a frame type system this is we
use this a lot of our experimental
designs and for one thing it's very easy
to harvest mushrooms as they produce
this is a much more promises to follow
Rick stack and it is very concentrated
there are a lot of mushrooms bottoms are
a lot of logs for a given area of the
ground
small footprint but you can imagine
wants to start producing mushrooms it's
going to be very difficult I think
it's down there on the bottom row we
have to spend the whole day lift the hip
off though that's not generally now I
said most my yard on level ground
sometimes rubber doesn't have much
little in Japan for example we have a
student in Japan working on and he
brought back this full-size back this is
really complicated
put together but it stands by itself
very steep slopes it's relatively easy
to harvest on if you put the brick staff
to put it on the steep slopes down okay
so you have to make log 4 5 here and
when you're ready to flush it produce a
bunch of mushrooms take the log this
world and put it in a tank of water cold
water for about 24 hours and that shops
it as we say physiologically you don't
understand what's happening there
anything within a week to seven days the
log will start producing mushrooms very
consistently if you're a much farmer
like Steve a girl or it's for Steve
Derrick who are here in the audience
they might be one of the one of those to
market let's say Farmers Market on
Saturday they can rely on soaking the
law of some previous Thursday ten days
later that alive without these mushrooms
will take the market if you let them
prove naturally such as comfort
sort of a thing here
once you take them out of the tank
you'll end up up gets something brother
and very good people for using any of
those other systems and then you put it
back on the stack and let it rest as
they say for six Danny please and then
even flushing again he had two flushes
or so each year for three or five years
so talk about our research shiitake has
been Brahman in North America since
early eighties nanawatai a shortage of
booklets and pamphlets and websites
howdy good but most of that production
is in the south southeast and out of the
Upper Midwest there's relatively little
production here in the Northeast
so our rationale has been that what we
want to do is develop the optimal
approaches or basement conditions some
of the variation regionally would be
substrate tree species they have a lot
of sweep done in the south and that's
one of the favorites pieces where we
don't have much rain sweep up here so
finding the appropriate tree species
to moisture management has to do with
the logs right now if the logs dry out
too much the sign whatever they're in
suffers no phone signal considerations
we have to lead through the product
calculation and finally fumble species
we're talking so far about shiitake but
there are some other species there
candidates such as the Lions
so it comes to of choosing appropriate
substrate in trees you often see and
much of the literature says that the oak
barrels like the best trees to use but
consider the fact that some wood a lot
of emergence of course numbers don't
have over or don't because other species
what can they do there are a lot of
other heartless deformities in our
candidate species and we set out to
determine what you want some
cost-effective
see if they will stand up to both this
is sort of goals so the ones that are
with the asterisks are ones that we have
tested our program here at one of the
tests we brought a couple years ago what
we have four species here muscle would
ask our clients
virginiana ran out of aquitaine is
Australia in fact a car - Carolinian
described protein and sugar - or just
testing all four of these trees there
they are up there and this guy here is
part - called fossil wood you can tell
the time ripoli sort of like sort of
like the possible I would
and so you can see after all this is the
sum of this is the sum of two years data
and you see that thread didn't do any
better than the Hawthorne being from
sugar what did the best in this trial
was the muscle will go there our finest
significant or fresh way so that sort of
the lives incredible supplication
here's up an experimental design
contested three substrate species with
some other variables as well there's
basically a three by four by two
complete factorial arrangement of
treatments looking at three different
fungal species
those are shiitake oyster mushrooms and
lion's mane mushroom I'll tell you why
the cross but in addition to that we're
looking at four different tree species
Fredo asked the beach and red maple
around here and then the to waxing
treatments what I mean here is we're
getting on the question of moisture
management how can we what is the
response to the law to find how far can
degrees so what we've done here to
basically test the hypothesis that the
moisture content of log will be related
to the cause decreased by compression to
test that hypothesis we have waxed a lot
of polls as I think it that's always
with that to keep the moisture in and
contaminants out but we've also tactical
auditing from these treatments we wax
the baseball other words you have a talk
of hot mobile hot molten facts we did
the end of the blog and turn it over to
the government and the idea is family
retardant oyster loss so here basically
then we took we're testing the substrate
pretty she's poster management and
compasses now the reason I crossed out
the moisture mushroom and the lines
means because in this experiment they
can't they produced almost
we repeated with some other approaches
and I come to conclude don't try to grow
as professionals on wood solid wood it
just doesn't work out very well we're
much much bigger sawdust straw copy
grounds from other more easily digested
substrates and the lies Bank using this
this bolt system the prequel
justice so here to see the results
in terms of the different species and
their effect on freshly over four
different seasons started the experiment
2006 we've got a few mushrooms of 2007
more
was down again we figured we decided
this was such low production in 2009 he
was pretty well spent but we thought
well hang on to them and next summer
we'll we'll soak them the water flush to
see if they had anything at all and sure
enough that's soaking resulted in a lot
of apartment production for that year
what do you
well I don't really know I mean this
this year they were just getting off
good often on the second year you really
get a good flushing and I thought this
was just the substrate with people's
awesome but it wasn't you have to flash
their camera the title perhaps the
temperature we put it anyway you see
here at the beach in two thousand ten
feet chopper form the other three
species and when you look at the total
of all four years
once again the beach Bruce is typically
more mushroom correctly than either the
red oak or the red maple and
consistently all years the Aspen better
I wouldn't recommend that as a substrate
of golf in that system
a source of moisture aspects of
experiments waters we set out to monitor
the moisture status law law Commissioner
content LMC and using two different
methods that are that are used for less
confident
there's no coking pathway by poking I
need to use your chainsaw to cut off a
one-inch thick section of law and it is
use the standard equation for the
moisture content the fresh weight of
that cookie reporter the drying up and
take the drive with difference between
the two divided by the fresh weight is
the law of moisture content as a
percentage or decimal correction and you
can't go wrong as long as your balances
in action so you get a fresh weight dry
weight you know what you're doing is not
going to have any source of variation
for it there's another approach that
sometimes using the reason has you cut
off a cookie every year for five years
you've lost a lot of law
this magnifico calculated undergraduate
method is a way to estimate that blog
post your content without destroying
that session long what it involves is
you start out at time zero you cut that
one quotient and you do the correct
weight by weight thing and you calculate
log moisture content like this and then
you multiply that long moisture content
by the fresh way to the wall so at the
same time you cut the quote take the
fresh waited my blog did write out just
the fresh way multiply beloved what you
want to freshly and you get the amount
of water in long and then subtract that
amount of water from the fresh waited
water I'm leaving with the estimate of
driving calculated and Riley so that
subsequently after six months after a
year or two you could simply way that
law fresh without cutting power cooking
and use this calculator driveway which
gently submit it's a constant throughout
this experiment subtract that couple
that I've read early from the fresh way
you can just take divided by the fresh
way to come up with an estimated law of
motion
this is this is what the results look
like using those two methods this is the
rookie method which is pretty much full
proof of thy stead the co VW method is
an estimate and it's generally assumed
at least early prolongs life with the
Broadway to walk doesn't change the
maitre it may voice term a be driven out
also the log loses weight that right
away stay possible for the pore size the
truth as the long ages fungus is
digesting the log and generate co2 dry
weight loss what was what was against
not too surprising wasn't using the
estimate CW the moisture content of all
four species seem to decrease pretty
rapidly but we know the other things are
a little bit funny when the moisture
content dropped below 25% that's
considered the lethal point the fortune
content which me the promise can no
longer survive my waters effectively
began except that our logs did not stop
producing mushrooms and the point five
when you look at the actual moisture
content by the somewhat surprised to see
them very little loss of moisture over
time and that all four species behave
pretty much the same now that may seem
counterintuitive but consider it this
way a lot of moisture evaporates you
have it out the center are there any
conditions it requires an evaporating
from the lawful trustee of the recently
and furthermore like a harvest mushrooms
pound of mushrooms has seven tensile
around the water they lose moisture
every time and when you have a couple
factors that are adding water to the log
rainfall of course some of its absorbed
increase in respiration is a big one
what you look at aerobic respiration
carbohydrate we broke it down into equal
parts
co2 and water and a lot of the weight of
that original carbohydrate this is for
this is a moisture which is within the
law so you're sort of recharging a lot
of moisture there are other other
factors when the respiration is
producing co2 which is being lost that's
Riley
so all things considered are our results
a consistent for the fact that the logs
do not lose my his lobster treatment
right captain the shade get out of the
lane and not allowed to lose a lot of
groceries
another factor that you mention here was
seasonal considerations and this is
actually enough substrate appeared with
two different spaces here but the rail
and the beach two of the mobs that we
had on a previous experiment basically
it turned out the same way the beach
produced significant congratulate then
they read it so that differences have
event the main effects concerning kind
of season were significant but there was
no interaction so we can look at these
two independent and when you do that
look at the different seasons we were
surprised we figured you know the
standard course of action is to take
your laws and populate them to the
spring but those were no different than
the winter inoculation that was in
October that was cut in February a lot
of inoculate
in February these were prepared in
spring in early June the summer
occupation was in Japan without high and
the fall of occupation my stars across
all inoculation is significant for
Marcus don't in winter or the summer so
when you think about this usually say
spring there's the best time to do it
but the farmers preventing the spread
and may not may not be an opportunity
time to do those activities so this
would suggest at other times a year
whereas framework would be more less
probable to the glare of some farmers
rules right involve the significantly
more than the winter summer
okay so we come back to these pieces and
I sort of miss one but in addition to
shitake we've been working with lines we
really excited about this jean race for
graduation for the records to started
working with linesman and it sort of
evolved from there the lion's mane is a
lot of confidence
it's a pressing species there are
several different species we work with
President Peres Neiges top floor like
structure and with ERISA America this is
one of the laws that we have inoculated
we use a total system instead of those
frequent long a h9 prolongs producers go
shiitake we time to take a B Street in
this case and cut all the section that
is about 12 inches in diameter 1 foot
long and that replace a a dull of spawn
sawdust spawn on the bottom place the
first section asset bubble between the
first and second and another dollop on
top cover them back
and we got fantastic production
appliances
this particular dog is about 2 pounds of
mushrooms very impressive
of course the season is much too dense
comparative shiitake but there have been
very few attempts to cultivate lion's
mane of course partner situation and we
think it has a lot of potential as
possibly a commercial problem it's
considered a real gourmet item five wild
lectures and so forth
so can we develop the point we're making
further growth well different areas an
Extension educator Ontario County and he
worked with us on one of our hatch
projects and done half the survey market
survey both mushrooms he interviewed
about 23 or 25 different restaurant
chefs the fine guys
and ask them which types of mushrooms
are they familiar with and do their
purchase and of course Portobello and
white
now to such a topic is for Reliance all
the way down the scale to Alaska the
coke light thing is next to the last
almost nobody knows about it so we have
a sort of uphill battle in terms of
marketing really aggressive attentions
to the people who need to talk here
venturous I guess what have we done
spare penalties like James started out
to do what we obtained to commercialize
local supply companies very few first
places so we've got that commercial
iceland and then we and Carlee river
collected isolates for a while in this
particular region so we have wild
lessons in other words you take on this
work out what this take a furnace
section
conditions plated out a potato [ __ ] go
slugger and Newsmax we're not too late
rain is falling sterile brain fog
mycelium colonizes the ring and then
transfer some of that into the sawdust
bag and it permeates the bag what G did
was relevant in these bags poking holes
inside that much of the movie that you
saw if you came in early that was a
Marisa function developing over a
four-day period can't lock but every
we've also been takin this sawdust
monocular and used it in that coated
consistent to section that I described
earlier here's the tort of being
inoculated there's moment right there it
will take it takes about 18 months
that's a much longer than the face
adventure photographer pretty good this
is not data for three successive years
first three years it wasn't much
production at all and last year
we've got papers you can see that the
ancient ice looks the ones with Jean and
Carl what the FFF III is commercialized
and outdoors and total system the
collected wildlife slits 85 and 83
outperform the commercial isolate okay
so what your ex elating all the screens
because negative safety lights we've
done from beach
whatever source influence how well the
strain will do experiments entirely each
barrel I think we now have and here is
the data that comes from this year come
see the different eye slits the
commercial FF isolate and eighty three
four and five and springtime and in the
fall semesters we're grabbing surprises
this year that there was a flush of
lion's mane mushrooms by the commercial
isolate in the spring it was early June
but none of the other localness was
produced anything the spring however in
the fall the situation was quite here
that there is little production from
this is hot off the press while having
cancer from statistics but it's pretty
obvious we have some substantial
differences here and there at least
looked at this both with respect to the
average mushroom production firm total
all with other believe lots of
differences or advertisement production
only way very encouraged by this
and
now the records have come to live there
by our outreach extensions I think it's
a very important partner take this this
is a media that we've developed for the
Sarah project that's the three-year
project here before last
it's a collaboration between Cornell the
VI Alan Alan Matthews is a COPI on from
University is a farm economist
specialist and so he's well equipped to
help us
artfulness fixes motivation Chicago
conferences before
professional safe release
basically this is a dishes this project
is intended to train forest owners
become commercial photographers not back
there she does a lot of those you know
we held workshops we want to welcome on
that occasion this three-year project we
started out with between mature peppery
workshops beginning of course I'm just
teaching those basic reductions and then
advanced workshop where the attendees
were given instruction in forest
management and site selection and the
marketing and commercial aspects and the
process all three of those
they were tend to both Vermont and here
attendees that we had an advanced
workshop as I say 105 people came to
that and out of those we asked people to
apply project
a fairly elaborate plans for probably
burgers mushrooms and we selected these
applications came up with 22 people
that was 2010 what they've done in
spring of this year is they have
inoculated 100 laws of their own cause
we had a source we did supply the spot
this year and so each of those 22 people
has inoculated on their own property we
sent out a member of our staff for a
site visit each time than we do anything
compilations we're able to deserve
observe and record what they were doing
as well as coming from so we're keeping
information about what they're doing but
they're also doing that themselves we to
get involved in this project they have a
breathing very detailed records of their
labor and their expenses and they're
eventually the idea is by the end of
next year next summer they should have
free food production production
statistics but also their nacelle
have data on all those activities the
ideas by the end of next year we'll have
partisan sales data we plan for fault
originally Chicago Forest elated
mushroom conference out of that tend to
get it develop the best management
practices you can see here the
distribution of the partners that were
dealing with
they're quite dispersed they span over
seven different states mainly north but
there are quite a few people it's not
just a local project
and they say record-keeping had been
important part of this project not only
by us but by them
we're look we're asking at what tree
species divisions
when did they fell the trees population
whether they knock you late and their
tracking their monitoring they were
labour inputs also looking at
first of all and this is typical this
isn't for our handler part that we're
putting together see the distribution of
people undertook these tasks they were
doing the log in as early as like
February about as late as April the
inoculation later taken away April so
we're able to tell you know I just want
everyone who we are with that's not all
we know there's going to be department
by department variation just give good
advice and document respect be quite
quite a lot of variation here some of
information on the average percentage of
time work by different individuals the
owner invested greater size with others
and volunteers of France what a
significant we're also looking at the
distribution of labor in terms of area
laying our maintenance cutting the
filter trees and inoculated respect this
change recently
this is greatest works with us so by the
time it's all over thing we're going to
have a better picture
the kind of variation occurs from our
department that offers recommendations
this looks like it's all the production
that is not the marketing and the
idealization not really supposed to
market happily
there's no we're going to certification
how many of these Hummers
none of them I got started because they
had to apply but it is really a rather
rather than a simple because all you
have to do is fill out the paperwork
nobody doesn't so it's pretty easy to
get certified and the supplier that
provided the spot for us they are
already certified there spawn certified
for
this just shows you on website this is
another extension happily however the
several years we started this website
that the hatch project that preceded
this era project but this is reflective
of the center front there is a little
parchment here's a map of the privilege
of google map on our website
this is a little much for everybody in
suppo the product is also established
farms like steve sara care and what you
do is you run the mouse over one of the
mushrooms a little window pops up and it
says top petal park which is Steve's
farm both the ingress and some comments
about what's going on there so this is a
tool that producers can use the public
can access information and find out
where they are
I just want to acknowledge a couple of
people here I've mentioned Steve Derrick
will speak Gabriel I don't have pictures
of you guys on the side right these were
folks who have worked with the project
for the last several years greater
brakeman of course was Boston Common she
doesn't so she was very involved in the
project for three years excellent
technician Tim + P is our technician
perfect I would share that self
he works so hard these are some other
people Rachel Brookings raise those ten
but her head is not rid of that flat
right so Karl expert
and then
why
was our summer intern every year program
whatever summer agra fort return she was
one this year and dad to listen to those
she is all these
they're all
Philippians love to find that effective
of what your company know you know
basically you saw that straight flat
line off the trees there was no
difference
so with all the be streets died at the
sparkle client we've been catching the
trees that are dead or dying does it
matter
for the harvest of fresh living healthy
pretty in order to the others we had
that whole experiment progress
people that have sort of the standard
with level ground but sounds like voice
your content wondering why we use and
what slopes or areas that
I already cut it it's going to be more
difficult to work with these water slope
and I think that's why I posted the city
level ground but as I say weekly have
been produced in this Japanese
I'm actually done forcing the creek
right now and what I do is I look at the
10-day forecast as long as I have
temperatures that look like they're
going to be favorable I've never forced
you talking this late in the year but as
long as because and there was one one
January where some of a lot of started
popping you thought the temperatures are
right what was the right thing is the
average temperature there's there's cold
weather Rajan's at shitake as well as
Chloe's most a wide range which are the
ones that respond to the forcing as long
as the average temperature for 10 days
is roughly 50 degrees
you'll get question rushing response
we weren't widely
heart is anybody tried under artificial
[ __ ] can't buck definitely they're
working what Google Circles can't be
like to do it we just take right now
shape right over the piles and works
I think it's not size that will affect
shake levels black there I didn't
mention it but there Bishop cotton
production indoors on a very intensive
conditions the same place that grows
unbelievable numbers of the white button
mushrooms Phillips mushroom and square
produces some shiitake as well they use
that plastic bag culture system and we
maintain
the marketing approach that a lot more
talking isn't very prominent if you've
ever seen it should talk to you later
it looks like shooting better and our
stuff just beautiful it's people
recognized
it was populated
Oh
we use the convention
what the chef's do
Kathy taught me to slice it up into down
sections limiting olive oil so it's nice
a lot of people put them in students
Susan it's a more dense texture right
and say you're talking
that's that applies to fresh
press our elicit does he cool
you know except what we're trying to
test our
what wiII happen if you put the walls
your surgeon you don't have any hair
there to Detroit
well we have the latest remember you saw
us blow pipe like this the first time
the bottom along with regular more food
was West
but moisture isn't in a particular
problem
so you should come
there's lots you can pose that years so
that I didn't refer to the drop side I
want to be not release the same logs or
do you have a hypothesis about what that
what it is about the different types of
wood that makes it better substrate
we're curious about that one thing that
I looked at was cm ratio they don't
differ substantially they have something
to do with their anatomical structure we
know the fungus moves rapidly through
the log vertically through dock with
vessels and migrates very slow laterally
but I
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu